[Music]
i have the great good fortune on this
january 15th 2021 of talking to mr
douglas murray the author of the madness
of crowds
gender race and identity douglas and i
met a couple of years ago and
got along quite remarkably well i think
we
did uh douglas was gracious enough to
mediate a discussion that i had with sam
harris in the
in what was the olympic stadium in
london if i remember correctly
um and we haven't we've talked a little
bit since then but it's been a couple of
years say
so i've just been reviewing the madness
of crowds this week again i
i read it when it first came out but i
was looking at it again i'm
looking forward to discussing a whole
variety of things with you some
associated with the book and some
not um but let's start with the book
at least some of the themes of the book
if you don't mind
you talked about you started by talking
about the collapse of grand narratives
and that's a theme that's very
interesting to me and
um i have a hypothesis that i'd like to
run by you and see what you think
i i've been talking to a friend of mine
here and we've been hypothesizing that
maybe there are two
large-scale grand political narratives
with an archetypal or mythological basis
and one would be
the promised land so that would be
the the bright future that we're all
headed to
and different versions of that would be
put forth by the right and the left but
the what what the hook is is that
something better awaits us and there are
certain strategies that we could use to
attain that
and if that fails then we have something
like the infidel
which is us versus them and so
one of the things that struck me when i
was reading your book was that
it isn't obvious that we have a promised
land narrative that's functional in the
west anymore
partly i think perversely because things
have improved so much
on the material front that it's not
really even obvious
how we could uh extend our
mastery of the material world to produce
a better future you know we've plucked
all the low-hanging fruit
and so that for most people i mean i
know inequality exists
i know there's relative poverty but
there's no straightforward solutions for
those either
or even solutions that necessarily would
appeal to the imagination and so maybe
we're stuck with some variant of the
infidel which is not a very
which is certainly not a grand narrative
that's designed to bring about
peace i don't know what you think about
that but i'd also like your
your take on grand narratives as such
and why you think they've collapsed
well first of all it's um really really
good to see you jordan thank you can't
tell you what a pleasure it is
um and i've missed you uh as as very
many people have
uh so it's really wonderful to see you i
appreciate that i've missed being
around believe me and and all the things
that i was engaged in hopefully that'll
start up again
with this as part of it i really hope so
um
yes it's been on my mind for a long time
i've written
around this subject in a couple of books
now that
that the oddity of the position of
western man at this point is that
he and she lack a grand narrative lack
an overarching explanation of what on
earth we're doing here
and i think you and i probably haven't
have the same experience that when
we were allowed to still congregate in
public spaces
whenever you addressed anything around
this issue
the hall fell silent you know i've
noticed for years
that there's all sorts of minou shy that
our societies are exceptionally good at
talking about
but we've become not only poor at
talking about but apparently
uninterested in the most important
questions of all
such as what exactly we meant to be
doing with our lives
what we meant to be doing with our time
we all know we've got a finite amount of
time
so how should we occupy that time well
and yeah well it's funny because i would
say in the past to some degree
that question was answered for us by
deprivation
you know it was obvious what we were
lacking and so
when it's obvious what you're lacking
when you're hungry when you're truly
hungry
there's no question about what you
should do you should eat and if you're
freezing and if you're overheated and
all of those things
the the desirable future manifests
itself
automatically in front of you and in
some sense we've been deprived of
deprivation and
and are suffering from um an enemy of
of prosperity yes and and and
um and i think for some people a form of
boredom
um and uh and yes and
too much time on their hands and and
much more there are different ways of
circling
around the same this the same answer to
the problem but
but it's been very striking to me for a
long time
that particularly in political terms the
left has been
really quite interested in this
gap it's it's it's recognized the
size of it and has sought to fill it
um in recent years as i say at the
beginning of the matters of crowds
the most obvious way of filling it is
with the
horrible and dysfunctional and
retributive replacement religion which
is identity politics
intersectionalism and all of this um
as i point out it's it's in some ways a
curiosity
perhaps also an inevitability that
let's say the respectable right at any
at any rate
um has been pretty uninterested in
answering these questions and hasn't
even nodded
to their absence the right has in our
lifetimes been very interested in issues
of economics and that's
of course crucial as you alluded to
earlier i mean
if the economics are going well you know
a lot of other things go well as well
when they go bad absolutely everything
goes bad
so in some ways it's understandable that
the right has been interested in
economic
questions but it has left the i didn't
as i said
repeat the sort of respectable bit of
the right has basically left identity
and meaning
questions uh to say well
you know find the meaning of things
where you will
um if you come across it great we
couldn't be happier for you
but doesn't seek to address these
questions well maybe it's partly because
the collapse of religious belief hasn't
been as
uh thorough on the right as it has been
on the left and still
there's still more people who are
oriented in the conservative direction
who have
some at least some vestiges of their
traditional religious belief
but you know yes well and i would say
too though that it isn't the left that's
been
concerned with our questions of identity
precisely i would say more
this is definitely the case in the
united states i think it's true in
britain and canada too that
it's the radical left because the
moderate
left i have a friend in la who's been
working on messaging
for the democratic party um he's been
doing that
pro bono as part of an independent group
of hollywood writers who've produced
about a billion dollars worth of
advertisements
they've been attempting to craft a
centrist democrat message
and it's quite difficult because well
and the reason they've been doing that
is because the
the radical left has a narrative and
regardless of what you might think about
it it has motivating power
and in the absence of any other
narrative it tends to dominate
and the problem with generating a
centrist narrative is that it tends to
be incremental
and incremental narratives tend not to
have much
persuasive power and so you might say
that what's happened is that there's
still a subset of people
who for whom for one reason or another
and that might be race or gender or
sexual identity or any of those things
any
any minority status that would bring
about it a felt sense of alienation
that the narrative is clear which is to
either restructure society so that
alienation disappears
or to well like that is the narrative is
to restructure society so that that
alienation disappears
yes and yes and even though that may not
be a narrative that works for everyone
the fact that nobody can construct one
that's more
compelling leaves a terrible void in the
middle and
it isn't obvious at all how that can be
solved yes
well by the way also we get back to one
of the problems that always exists for
people on the right or certainly for
small c conservatives
which is that they always end up
fighting the next battle they're going
to lose
precisely because of this phenomenon
that the left and the radical left
advances ideas
the right doesn't know conservatives
don't know how to defend
um things such as
precedent tradition
just doing things the way you've always
done them and recognizing that there's a
virtue in that
um well it isn't it isn't that easy to
sell
a story that's that's well things are
pretty damn good and
try not to do anything stupid to muck it
up like and the reason for that is that
there's no real direction in it
and that's especially true for people
who aren't fully ensconced within the
society and
and feeling that they have an integral
role to play so it doesn't work for
conservatism doesn't work for felt
outsiders
yes it it it looks um among things
self-satisfied i think it's one of the
reasons why a certain
radical young person uh rejects a
conservative narrative because they say
it it only works if things are going
well for you i mean
again i would dispute that but but it's
it's a tendency people have
um the other issue though on this is
that conservatives in in general
uh it's part of the conservative mind
are
resentful of and distrustful of people
coming along with grand narratives
um this is this is obviously a burkian
insight
why burke takes a view he does of the
events in france
and writes about in the reflections it's
it's the most common trend for
conservative thought is a suspicion of
thought
a suspicion of thinking and of
philosophy and of grand ideas
precisely because of an innate
recognition that such
ideas can go so very badly yes yes
it leaves and i've always thought that
this is that this is a
both it's mainly seen as a disadvantage
of conservatism
in fact of course it can be a very
distinct advantage
um but it only works as an advantage
if things are going very badly wrong in
whatever the utopian grand narrative
project is that's being proposed
um you know it's only when everything
goes badly wrong with the utopianism
that people realize
the virtues of the conservative system
you know it's only after the french
revolution when you
when you've got the famines because
you've killed all the people who know
what to do it's only after the russian
revolution
when everyone's starving because the
bolsheviks don't know how to do the most
basic things in food production that
people start to realize the virtue
of the the kind of conservatism that i'm
describing
but until that moment of total collapse
utopian radical left is always going to
be at a distinct advantage
he's got a it's got a sexier product to
sell
well the other problem is of course and
this has to do i think with the way
people are wired biologically
with regards to their emotional
responses is that
if everything is going well everything
that's going well
is invisible yes because we're throwing
we're so threats we we habituate to
anything that's predictable
and we're very sensitive to threat so
even when many things are going wrong
well we're going to pay attention to
those things that aren't and we're not
going to pay attention to everything
that
that is working to maintain say this
amazing infrastructure around us which
a conservative would say well it's very
unlikely that this degree of stability
and wealth can exist let alone be
maintained and we should be very careful
with it
but yeah but that's that it's a hard to
keep the
the impulse going for that narrative
because it isn't
it that isn't how we work emotionally
partly because it's not efficient to
constantly be grateful for things that
are predictable
it takes too much mental energy now that
doesn't mean
that doesn't mean that the grand
narrative that's put forth by the left
and
and you talk about this particularly in
terms of let's say
identity politics and intersectionality
identity politics seems to be predicated
on the idea that
certain certain
rather arbitrarily selected features of
individuals
constitute the core element of their
identity
i've never been sure exactly why it's
those
um it's the particular elements that are
concentrated on
race sexuality gender sexual proclivity
say
why those tend to be the hallmark and
maybe it's
maybe it's because there do you think
it's reasonable to pause it that it's
because
that the leftists look at groups that
have in fact experienced
some degree of prejudice or alienation
in the past and
and then and then make that make
whatever it was that produced the
alienation the central characteristic of
their identity
yes and well there's that and there's
also the other one which is the illusion
that you can
do very much about it i mean
in our age uh and obviously they're the
issues i write about in matters of
crowds
the the the presumption seems to be and
the selection seems to be something
around
the idea of there's something you can do
about it now by the way this is a very
confused narrative
because it both says that there are as i
say in the book there are hardware
issues and software issues and it
pretends that the software issues the
hardware
and the hardware issues can be software
and it doesn't really know what to do
for instance it says that sexuality is
definitely hardware
whereas sex is software that just
doesn't run as a
simultaneous program um and it says
we don't really know what race is and it
gets into a hell of a lot of trouble and
dodges it on race
um it says that the only the only thing
people are legitimately born into as an
identity is being trans and so all of
this is
incredibly messily ill thought out
but i i have wondered whether it has
something to do with this thing of
you can do something about it because if
you selected
height which is obviously one of the
other ones you could do which has a
profound impact on people's lives yes or
attractiveness
yes there's just there's just at some
point you have to come across the thing
that there's nothing you can do about it
and
um i would have thought that the age
would
be grown up enough or could be grown up
enough to recognize that that is the
issue
on a set of identity questions as well
that
you know when a famous pop star says as
he did recently
that he'd like to be a mummy by the age
of 35
the age treats him as the people doing
monty python's life of brian
and say where's the fetus going to just
state
um in a bucket um you know in a box
in other words the the age wouldn't
simply keep
saying oh yes that's possible that's
plausible
so it's deeply confused i'm trying to
analyze
it is in some way adding adding
confusion
to it i simply i i'm simply struck by
the fact that
that there are a number of very major
issues that occur in people's lives that
are darked by the age
um i don't know why they've ducked them
other than and this is this is the best
approximation i can do
is that they've chosen the ones they've
chosen because they know that they will
cause maximal annoyance to conservatives
that they have the best chance of
breaking down some of the most reliable
structures that we still have in our
society
and that they baffle and confound people
well it could be
it could be simpler than that though and
maybe less in some sense less
conspiratorial is that
the identity politics identity politics
coalesces around any group
where there's sufficient where there's a
sufficient number of people with at
least one thing in common who do in fact
feel
alienated and resentful about the
general culture
for for for valid and invalid reasons
and so it's a crapshoot in some sense it
doesn't matter if there's consistency
in category structure across the
different categories of identity
politics all that matters is that enough
people will coalesce around each term
and yes i think that's reasonable
because many many terms have been
generated like ageism for example
although we haven't seen
we haven't seen much of a politic of
identity politics emerge around age
but that's probably because it didn't
coalesce you know you could think about
it as a darwinian process in some sense
is that
there's a hundred terms of alienation
and ten of them
generate enough social attention to
become
viable sociological and political
phenomena
and and they continue to breed but
that's because they breed whenever
there's enough
people to garner enough attention now
the problem i have with that and this is
something else i wanted to talk to you
about in detail is that
because i've been thinking about this
for a long time is
the notion of identity that lurks at the
bottom of this
because i think part of the problem with
the identity politics
grand narrative is that partly because
of its incoherence it doesn't offer
anything that that looks like a real
solution
so well and that's partly because of
it's it has
its definition of what constitutes
identity seems to me to be
almost incomprehensibly shallow
especially for social constructivists so
so the idea i don't think i'm parodying
this the central idea seems to be that
identity is something that you
define yourself and it's a consequence
of your lived experience and so no one
has any right to
state anything about your identity other
than you because they don't have access
to your own subjective experiences
and look i don't i don't want to i i
i wouldn't want to make the claim that
there's no there's nothing in that
because there is a domain of subjective
experience that's unique
and like pain for example and there's no
doubt that it's real and
and that it's vital and important but
the problem with that seems to me to be
is that
identity isn't only a consequence of
your subjective experience
in fact it's not even a label for your
subjective experience
identity seems to me to be a a handbag
of tools
that you employ to make your way in the
natural and social world
so it's more like a pragmatic it's
something more pragmatic it's like the
rule you might play if you were playing
a game with other people
and you can pick your role you can pick
your role but it has to be part of the
game
and that means that people have to
accept you as a player
and that there are certain functions
that you have to undertake when you
fulfill that role and that's actually
beneficial to you right because
partly what you want from an identity is
a set of guidelines for how it is that
you should act in the world
and the problem with a lot of these
newer categories and i think trans is a
good example of that is that
even if the category was accepted as
valid
on the grounds of its um proposed
validity which is the felt sense of
being a man if you're a woman or being a
woman if you're a man
it isn't obvious what that buys you
you know and i just interviewed i just
interviewed abigail schreier who wrote
irreversible damage and she talks about
some of the consequences now obviously
her book is quite
controversial in fact i was terrified to
even talk to her
to be honest um she's a very brave
person and
i've had a fair bit of that beat out of
me i'm afraid um
but it isn't obvious it's obvious that
adopting the identity of trans and then
pursuing that down the medical
alteration route carries with it some
vicious consequences oh yeah
yeah so let's talk about identity yes
i i am i agree it does it
provides you it provides you with a path
that's one thing that i've
i've noticed i've noticed i noticed when
i was interviewing various trans people
for the madness of crowds
um i noticed that it provides a path
um of what you're going to do um
and it's and this is one of the things i
noticed sort of early about that
question was it seemed to be an
explanation of a kind
uh for instance you feel um
slightly alien in the world
it will be solved in this manner and
there's a place you can go
and well all of us at some level
and some people throughout their lives
feel
great disjunction with the world that we
find ourselves in
it isn't at all clear to me that there
is any answer whatsoever to that
no it's a permanent existential problem
right that's man against
society essentially and we're all
crushed and formed by society to our
detriment and to our benefit
yes and and and not just what society
does trust but
our experience of life with or without
society
to the extent that we can study man
outside of society
it's what kierkegaard and others keep
going around what it is that we cannot
know
what it is we intuit about our condition
in the world which we still
can find no way of expressing or finding
our way to
um there are great mysteries about
ourselves
which we intuit and we cannot answer
and obviously it's what philosophy
uh uh continually returns to
it's what religion uh uh attempts to
answer
and these are the deep questions of of
humankind it it's it's why all of this
constantly crosses against and it goes
across for instance aesthetics
because because our senses our late
friend roger scrutin
are often described better than anyone
um
our sense of beauty is is so important
because it gives
us a sense of that thing we know and we
know we cannot approach
um something which is is telling us
something from a realm which we know
we cannot access or can never access
fully these are these are central
aspects of being a human being and
and and and one of them as i say is the
sense which exists in all our lives
at some point and for some people
semi-permanently
that that the world is is
totally um unknowable to them and
therefore they are
highly vulnerable to anything that comes
along and says
this is the answer and i i know well you
you point out in your book
this is something quite interesting that
supports this line of reasoning which is
you you talk about the stripping of
a particular identity from someone who
if they
evince the wrong political platform so
peter thiel for example
can't be gay because he's a republican
and kanye west
can't be black because he came out in
favor of trump and
yes that does argue the fact that that
occurs
that stripping of the identity occurs
does indicate that the identity has a
function
and and yes and a purpose right so it's
a way
it has a platform it has a party
uh manifesto it's something to sign up
to
yeah and in the absence of nothing or in
the absence of anything else it might be
better than nothing
absolutely the question is how tenable
it is and
and and and the the fundamental flaw
that i
see in identity politics is that
even though it's predicated on the idea
at least
it's simultaneously predicated on the
idea that so that identity is a
social construct and that it's a felt
sense and it can't be both of those
and it is in fact a social construct
with biological
with biological root the fact that it's
a social construct
means that it's something that is by
necessity negotiated with others not
imposed upon them by fiat
and it has to be negotiated with others
because otherwise
they won't play with you
this is one of the reasons why to an
extent i i think i say somewhere in the
book that
trying to find the exact methodology of
the prevailing ideology of our era
is to a great extent like trying to find
meaning in the entrails of a chicken
and we do just keep coming across the
same
set of unexplainable inexplicable
contradictory self-contradictory ill
thought out ideas
um the most obvious ones i i i say
somewhere is
a number of other people pointing this
out now as well is is
you must understand me indeed your
primary role in the world almost is to
understand
me if i'm in the right set of categories
um
and simultaneously you will never
understand
right right now i mean as i say i
i think actually it's it's fairly
obvious that
if you can never understand where
somebody else is coming from then
there's no point in discourse
there's no point in speaking with other
people or of reading or of learning
we just we are in solitude
all these things that's a hobbesian
state that's absolutely that's a state
of war
absolutely when conversation ceases war
emerges
exactly we can't understand each other
there's no there's no
recourse except for force and this is
why this obviously
this is why it worries me so much when i
hear this done by
particularly by identity politics people
in relation to race and particularly
obviously to do
it if you happen to be black is if
people say you can
never understand my experience i think
but if if if a person who is not black
can never understand the person who is
then we're in for a hell of a lot of
trouble like step
back from that we have to work hard at
trying to
understand each other including each
other's historic pain
including each other's current
situations but we have to keep open
the possibility that we can and will
try to understand each other and to
speak
across these alleged vast divides which
i don't think are remotely
as big a divide if they are a divide as
the various as i say people who believe
this ethos
of our time claim but but this is the
one that worries me most and it's
profoundly anti-human apart for anything
else
because if you say sign up be a part of
one of these groups
and then you've got this sort of as i
say party manifesto
set out it completely ignores what most
of us find
to be our experience i think if we're
honest as human beings
which is that we like to be able to
absorb
we like to be able to understand we like
stories
we like to hear about people who are not
like us
from the very beginning we read stories
about
people who have no connection with our
kind
why did children across the world read
about
princesses and princes and
all sorts of other people who are
nothing like in the state they are
because we like to hear
other people's stories it's not just
that they're architects we want to find
out about other people we don't
just want the experience that we happen
to have been or being born
into that's because that's because that
broadens our identities
yes it gives us more tools to to
use in the world and we're obviously
very good at that and it is
a matter of throwing your hands up in
despair if you say that that's
impossible
it's difficult i mean we're each a
solitude in some sense for multiple
reasons
for maybe multiple intersectional
for that matter but that doesn't mean
that
communication is impossible or that it
should be forgotten unless you want the
alternative and the alternative is
conflict combat yes yes
if i can't understand you you're nothing
like me
and there's no way that we can negotiate
any peaceful way to occupy the same
space
that's right and so that's a maybe
that's the catastrophe you're after but
it's not
it's not an optimal outcome no and
um it's one of the reasons why my ears
have been particularly pricked in
in recent years by um
a certain retributive rebarbative
deliberately callous discussion
of certain groups of people
certain types of voters and much more
a gleeful willful desire
not to even bother to try to understand
their pain
which is of course as far as i can see
it nothing more than an expression of
assumed generally vengeance
well that that brings us to another okay
so let's let's dive into that a bit
obviously at least to some degree you're
referring to what happened in the united
states with regards to trump voters
and that's basically half the population
yeah well let's
let's start there because that's a good
rat's nest to try to investigate so
um what i see
and have seen happening in the west but
particularly in the united states in
recent years
is the beginnings of something that
resembles a an out of control positive
feedback loop
and a positive feedback loop you know
this but i'll just outline it
quickly a positive feedback loop loop
occurs when the inputs of a system
and the outputs are the same and so you
hear this when you hear feedback
at a rock concert when a microphone gets
too close to a speaker
because the microphone picks up the
speaker noise and then transmits it to
the speaker and then runs it through the
microphone
amplifying it each time until the whole
system
goes out of control essentially and a
lot of forms of psychopathology are
positive feedback loops
like depression when you get depressed
your mood goes down and then you start
to
isolate yourself and and get estranged
from the people that you love and your
friends and that makes you more
depressed and that makes you more
estranged and then you start not going
to work and that
alienates you and makes your depression
worse and you spin
downwards and um
positive feedback loops can erupt in
societies too and you get that in
societies that are in permanent feuds
which is part of the reason that the
state has to exercise a monopoly on
violence
it's to stop vengeful retribution from
spiling out of control
it's a real danger and what i see
happening right now is that
the right and the left are engaged in a
process of
positive feedback where one hits the
other
and the other hits back slightly harder
and then well
i don't have to belabor the point um
and i think that if you're
temperamentally inclined to be on the
right you point to the left and you say
well they started it and if you're
temperamentally inclined to be on the
left you point to the right and say well
they started it and
you or and here's how they're
contributing to it and you can point to
innumerable
examples and
where where it all started is a rather
arbitrary choice on your part
the question for me is how to dampen it
down you know
and conservatives have a real problem at
the moment i believe because of what
happened with trump in recent weeks and
so
let me tell you what i understand and
you tell me what what you think okay
i mean um i regarded trump as a reaction
to clinton essentially and to her
playing identity politics and i believe
that trump didn't win so much as hillary
lost
and she lost because a sizable
proportion of her base
the the working-class white males
basically
the tr who were traditionally democrat
when push came to shove choosing between
her and trump
chose trump mostly as an up yours to
the democrats and so i don't see trump
trump's a symptom although he's also a
causal agent
now unfortunately what's occurred in the
last couple of weeks
has made things unbelievably complicated
because it does look like
trump went down the rabbit hole of the
stolen election
um narrative and has caused a
substantial amount of grief and misery
as a consequence of that
and so well so i'd like your opinion
about all that and then we can discuss
what might be done about that from the
conservative perspective or indeed
period
yes i i i will just speaking agree with
what you just said
i um i was in the uh the states
for a month and a bit more before the
election traveling around covering it
and i hadn't been to the u.s for a
couple of years as it happened i travel
a lot as you know
in normal times but i hadn't been to the
u.s for a couple of years
and i was horrified by the fact that
just normal
discourse seemed to be impossible across
political divides
all dinner tables uh erupted
uh um in exactly the the the fashion
that you
you would expect everyone's darkens in
their own
positive feedback loops but you did this
first
but your side did that and as you say
you could start from anywhere but
that was that was the nature of it but
there was something
else by the way which was i mean my
fairest estimation of the critique
that the left has of the right is
that they hate the right for allowing
trump to happen
and that that isn't such a bad reason to
dislike the right at the moment
um how did you allow this man uh out how
did you allow them to win
that that seemed to be their their
criticism and there is a criticism to
make of the american right over that
i think it could have been a hell of a
lot worse um but but it's a reasonable
criticism for the right to contend with
uh the problem is well the right has to
contend with
the potential power of a kind of
mindless populism
just as the left has to contend with the
constant potential to be swamped by
intellectual like ideology
and so
if the left tends to
go out of control in an intellectual
direction
an ideological intellectual direction
and a lot of that is explicit in the in
say in the identity politics ideology
that's that's
that's paramount now and and maybe it
was explicit in the form of marxism
earlier the right can easily respond to
that with a pronounced
implicit anti-intellectualism and i
think that's exactly what trump
represented
i mean it's funny because he was a kind
of elite obviously he comes from a
wealthy background but he wasn't
markedly part of the insider
intellectual elite and he was able to
express the frustration of the common
person so to speak
with the idiocy of the intellectuals
um in the in the manner that he acted
essentially and in whom he had contempt
for
i suppose and um you could blame that on
the stupidity of the
people who voted for trump but you could
equally point to the
red flag that was being waved in front
of their face by the identity politics
types and again that's another
place where a positive feedback loop can
easily become instantiated
the issue is how to dampen this down
well what so
that one of the other things i noticed
was of course on the right there was a
certain type of
voter on the right in america who didn't
just make peace with trump which was
something that you could
do i i wrote about this a number of
times you could say well these are the
things he did which are
reasonable or you know we're in power so
we should try to make sure that we
exercise it well and and have whatever
impact we can to improve the
administration these there was something
else going on
which was um people recognizing
that trump hurt their opponents
you know that he was a low tool to get
back at the left now i i've heard that
everywhere over weeks
you know that like they've yeah
definitely there was an element of
vengefulness
exactly it was up yours so the left have
kept producing people who've been
provoking us and prodding us
and we on the right in america keep
producing
sort of you know third presses
of the bush family or various other
dynastic politics that corrupts america
we keep producing them that and we're
just not giving
anyone of equal vengefulness
lowness um a willingness to just
hit people nastily if they come
trump was willing to do a lot of that
stuff if not
all of it and a certain type of
right-wing voter had had enough
and was willing to was willing to get
the only
person willing to play the left on equal
terms and one other thing from that of
course
he he did something that again the right
has
historically sort of not been very good
at which is having a program of his own
not just fighting the next battle you're
going to lose you know if the
battleground
people tend to think of the battleground
of politics as being sort of
level and it isn't at times it tilts
more one way than the other
so at times historically it's harder to
advocate left-wing proposals on certain
things
and then it suddenly becomes all
downhill it becomes easy to do it
um it's in the same way the right tends
to be
at a disadvantage constantly having to
push uphill and inevitably what it does
is it makes a compromise with the latest
left wing command
and therefore the left actually
accumulates a bit more power a bit more
influence a bit
more furtherance of its ideology and and
that
that that slightly sloped uh situation
had existed in american politics on in
the views of a lot of people on the
right
for some years donald trump comes along
and seems to do that
to it he seems to be willing to say no
no we're not just going to be on the
back
foot fighting the next thing the left's
going to win we're actually going to do
stuff of our own
and that is a dynamic that had been
missing in american politics and i think
to that extent a certain type of
right-wing voter
was willing not just to be uh to make
peace with trump
but actually willing uh to give him the
benefit of the doubt and indeed to allow
him to use
uh the tools of government when i
channeled my inner redneck which wasn't
that difficult
given that i'm from alberta which is a
rather conservative and
sort of self-consciously proud redneck
texas of canada i suppose
and i'm not saying that in an entirely
disparaging way there's certain
advantages to that
anyways when i was channeling my inner
redneck i could certainly
come into contact with feelings of
exactly that type it was
because i could imagine myself in the
bellying chamber
reaching out to put the check mark next
to hillary's name and saying oh to hell
with it
which is a hell which is a hell of a
thing to say in the ballot room and
putting a check by trump's name
you know and you can do that quite
easily too when you think well it's just
your vote it's
one among you know millions of votes and
what difference does a little
impulsiveness on
and a little vengefulness on my part
make and
trump was definitely a candidate of
resentment although
i think you could say exactly the same
thing about hillary and
the fact that we had candidates of
resentment is a bad
that's bad because resentment resentment
is a terrible terrible motivation
absolutely one of the worst and it is
tended to be
identified with the left on politics and
i think now it is equally at least
able to be uh identified with the right
but here we come to the
to what i regard as being the real
challenge and to answer the the deep
underlying question of how we try to
improve this
um in in america the thing that struck
me most was this
i and i wrote about this in spectator
recently i was very worried by one thing
in particular which
is what happens when you don't just have
different interpretations of events
but the thing that you've just seen you
disagree on the nature of what it was
you saw
oh yeah opinions nothing man it's
disagreement about facts that's
everything and that's perception
now now in in political terms in
democratic terms
this is of course an absolute
catastrophe because
as i was saying some friends in britain
recently you know
the great one of the great things about
democratic politics
isn't just that it gives you a winner it
gives you a loser
you know by 1997 the conservatives have
been in power for 18
years most of them under margaret
thatcher
and then under a weak successor
and by 1997 the british public have had
enough of the conservatives the best
interpretation
is that they have become weak and they
were very very weak
they also appeared to be slightly
corrupt around the edges
they seemed to be to be all sorts
they seem to be hypocritical on morality
issues and much more the country had had
enough
of them and they voted them out in a
landslide
and for 13 years conservative party is
in the wilderness trying to work out how
to be
appealing to the electorate again and it
manages it
in the same way by 2010 the labour party
the labour left
have frankly become um have become a
bore to the public
they've been in office long enough we've
got the successor to tony blair just
like we had the successor to margaret
thatcher
we're on the weak and falling apart
slightly
slightly i don't use the word in a real
sense but a sort of corrupted
part of the political system it's late
in the day
and the public vote the conservatives
back into office albeit only in a
coalition at first
but the important thing about this is
what does the party do in the interim
in the case of the uk the left after it
loses the 2010 election
goes slightly further to the left and
then crazily far to the left
and then last year in 20 20 20 the
british public
in its genius totally rejects the far
left-wing politics of jeremy corbyn and
now the labour party is in the process
of trying to make itself electable again
and coming into the center why do i give
this
most of your viewers um obscure lesson
in the last few decades of british
politics because the most
important thing in a way was not who won
but who lost and what they did when they
knew they lost yes
and yes as you know psychologically this
is one of the most important lessons
freud writes about this in um the essay
on what's it
on melancholia that that that you
that you have to be able to recognize
that the thing has been
lost in order to be able to even love
again
you have to bury the thing that has been
lost to recognize that it is gone
and what i am horrified by in american
politics
is the fact that that mourning process
is not
allowed to occur they cannot bury the
dead
they cannot grieve for the loss because
they don't think they lost
you know half of the half and again i
don't
make there's a technical problem there
too which is that
the margin of victory wasn't much
greater than the margin of error
you know and that and that's been a
problem for multiple elections now right
four elections in a row it's been being
too close to call
and you know there is always a certain
amount of corruption in every
in any electoral process maybe it's half
a percent or a quarter of a percent in
a pristine system but when your margin
of victory is
of the same magnitude then yeah well
then you can make a plausible case that
corruption has
has potentially undermined the validity
of the process it's
absolutely and you know both sides i i
i'm not simply making an equivalence
here but
i mean both sides have tried this in
american politics in recent years
you know it's not like it was obscure
democrats who pretended that trump was
an illegitimate president who had not
been legitimately voted in 2016
it was not obscure figures it was the
woman who was defeated by him at the
ballot box
who was among the people who played with
the idea
first of all we had that the russians
that actually manipulated the ballot
machines
remember that you know they all walk
back from it now that they were or they
pretend they didn't do it but they were
literally pretending and claiming that
the russians had managed to get access
to the voting machines in america in
2016.
and then they sort of slowly stepped it
back and they had that the russians had
sort of financed stuff and then it was
russian bots
but for four years the democrats played
with that
trump then totally reprehensibly
takes that even further and says that
the election results can't be accepted
and he won't even leave
office is is is the first reaction
which obviously is playing with the most
dangerous elements of the democratic
process
and so so now nine out of ten trump
voters now still say they believe he won
the election
in terms of healing this the first thing
i can come up with on this the first
thing the most basic thing
is that joe biden after coming into
office has to make sure this never
happens again how does that happen i'm
not an american i can only make as it
were friendly suggestions
i would just make sure that the next
president makes sure this can
never happen again that there is some
bipartisan non-partisan
way in which they agree who
wins the election next time around and
that four years from now
whoever hypothetically that's what the
electoral college was supposed to be
doing
absolutely and i suppose it didn't
perform that function but was still
i i do think again it's a problem of of
margin of error
a technical problem of margin of error
you know it's
you can't you can't expect anything
other
than for there to be questions about the
validity of an election when it's that
close it's going to happen
well you know you you you can have these
questions but as long as you respect
the outcome i mean you can have very
close elections and still accept them
yes in 1997 there was a conservative
seat which i think
was lost by nine votes
and they got recount after recount and
eventually actually there was a re-vote
and the conservatives lost by about 20
000 votes because the voters were so fed
up with the conservatives
making them vote again now but the point
is is that it was very
close but but it would have been
respected
that it it isn't just it isn't just the
closeness of the elections in america
although i agree it's obviously no well
i'm not trying i'm certainly not trying
to justify it either i'm just saying
that
this eventuality is much more likely
under those circumstances absolutely but
but but this this process that they're
now stuck in of just not agreeing on
what they just saw
is is is lethal so
okay so let's let's talk about that for
a minute too because this brings up
another technical issue
and the because you you opened the can
of worms by stating that
people now don't have differences of
opinion about the facts they have
different
facts yes and the question is
in part how is it under normal
circumstances that people do
see the same facts but then have
different opinions it means there's a
very deep consensus on top of which
there's
relatively trivial dispute that's a much
better situation
but part of the way that people do that
is by using
um well look look at it this way you
have five senses
each of which depend on a very different
physiological mechanism and that's
because you can see
things that aren't there and you can
hear things that aren't there and you
can touch things that aren't there
but you can't see hear and touch things
that aren't there
so you use this multi-dimensional
process
of of uh of triangulating
you actually use pentangulating i
suppose with your five senses and
you determine what's real but even
that's not enough
then what we do is we seek consensus we
say okay well here's
what the phenomenon appears to be to me
what do you see and then if you see it
and someone else sees it and this would
especially be good if we didn't share
the same opinions but we could agree on
what we saw then we think it's real
now the technical problem is now
no matter what you believe you can find
a like-minded group
that's discussing this avidly to
to confirm your confirmation bias and
what that means and i'm seeing this
happening
i can't believe how rapidly it's
happening i'm seeing people
degenerate into a conspiratorial
paranoia
and i'm seeing it in family members and
in absolutely and in friends and
like and as well as manifesting itself
in broader society and it's really
i think we're driving ourselves insane
with the net yes i
i absolutely agree i'm very very worried
about where we are
and i'm in political terms i mean it's
obviously deeper but in political terms
i'm worried about it because i think the
right is about to go off in america like
the left in america has gone off
well that was that was the likely
outcome five years ago it looked to me
like that was
it's why i tried to
i was concerned back in 2016 that things
were starting to degenerate and that the
left would wake up
the sleeping right you know the the
radicals on the far end of the spectrum
who
prefer action to words let's say by a
large margin
and who are truly dangerous i could see
them being
prodded into awakeness and it was a very
frightening thing
it still is a very frightening thing i
mean one of the things i've thought
about a lot in recent years about this
is of course is
is is is not just there's that
possibility of the
the two sides fighting it against each
other but
but there ends up being no place to
trust each other this is the i mean this
seems to me
in my conversations with people of
different political types what i notice
is
that there is the most important thing
if you're actually going to solve a
problem and you know better than anyone
how
how much the political talk shall we say
is actually not
set up to solve problems it's set up for
a performative thing
it's set up for people to just play
their part
and read the script and and
almost none of our political discussion
is actually problem
solving oriented almost none of it um
but when you do when you do get close to
solving a problem
it exists and it exists the possibility
only exists
if the other person is is
able to be trusted by you
not to pull some funny stuff when you're
not looking
and i was thinking about this recently i
was thinking about this reason i was
in america and i was talking at one
point with brett weinstein on his
podcast and
and you know i completely bret is
brett is from a very different political
uh um
tradition from for me we have very
different instincts on an awful lot of
things
and a lot of very similar instincts but
when i talk with bret about
problems like uh i know we talked about
poverty and homelessness and things
i i completely trust him
and he allows me to concede where i'm
not
willing often to concede because i'm i'm
slightly worried that
you know for instance let me give the
obvious one i worry about the inequality
discussion like a lot of people on the
right not because i don't believe
inequality exists
but i worry that the people who've been
thinking about it most are the ones with
the worst
possible answer you know yes
that's another thing we should discuss
because inequality is a
terrible terrible problem it's a society
devouring problem
the only thing worse than inequality are
the purported solutions
frequently exactly so and it's it's it's
it's perfect example of it because
um every political side has a version of
this you know
what you the i think i think well we've
talked about this a bit in the past
i think one of the reasons that the
right finds it so hard to persuade the
left
to talk about immigration for instance
is the left just doesn't
want to acknowledge it's it's the
serious debate it is
because it notices the right is the side
that's been thinking about it most
and it doesn't trust the answers the
right has
so it's it's it's definitely something
that both sides have as
an instinct so how do you solve a
problem in this
situation only by people from across the
political divide
trusting each other that that they that
they don't have
something funny they're going to pull
when you're not looking or
to put another way they're not going to
do something when you're beyond your own
competency on the subject you're trying
to solve
so that that's how you actually solve a
problem
now of course as i say we're not solving
any problems at the moment and i noticed
this i i said that the last couple of
years is like the eye of sauron
our society particularly whipped up by
the wretched social media companies that
make them rich have turned our societies
into a great eye of sauron which scours
across the land
and it looks at one thing dementedly and
then it moves on to another thing and
the problem about it is it doesn't solve
a damn
thing none of the things none of the
things it focuses on you know it focuses
on
on um on oh
what did we have we had oh we had a
green issue in january it was meant to
be a climate emergency of january of
last year every
every democratic government was meant to
announce a climate emergency then we
have the covid emergency
then we have the blm emergency you know
it's been emergency after emergency and
we don't seem to solve them in fact we
seem to
we seem to make them worse when we
address them
because we can't agree on the thing that
we're meant to be addressing so as i say
if
if if if i was to try to try to come up
with the things to solve this it would
be that
that people from the left and right who
could trust each other but
and just just one other thing on that
the thing about that is
the reason why i think we haven't been
able to do that particularly in america
is this in my view the american left has
an
incorrect approximation of the proximity
of fascism to the american political
system
you know or white nationalism to the
center of the political system and
obviously trump has given them a heck of
a lot of ammunition
but they were willing to use it anyway
they've been using it for years
they wanted to claim they basically that
fascism was very very close
now you see scenes like the
reprehensible scenes at the capitol the
other day
and you see the ammunition that these
reprehensible people have just given the
left to continue to pretend
that the american right all of the right
you know cnn presenters and others have
said all of the right
is now with the nazis with
the fascists with the the white
supremacists
and if that's the case you can't if
you're on the american left communicate
with anyone on the american right
because when you're not looking they're
going to smuggle fascism in
and get you all and the problem is that
an element of the right
look sometimes it's a reasonable
critique distrusts the left
because it doesn't trust that its social
welfare instincts aren't going to be
then subsumed into their socialist
instincts
aren't then going to be subsumed by a
deep desire to have communism
so so the right doesn't trust now i
think there are elements of the right
that have particularly in america deeply
overstated
the proximity of communism
to the american political system
just do you think i'm one of those no i
don't no i don't why not
well i think it's something i worry
about you know when i'm looking at this
positive feedback loop situation arise
you know i can't help but see
similarities
in the social identity movement and the
marxist movement
and i i mean you make that case in your
book so maybe you're one of them too
you know
i and i don't know if this is a
situation where
you know the left purports to see
fascism lurking behind every right-wing
move and
do you think the right is just as
culpable with regards to seeing
communism behind every left-wing move i
mean i think it's
complicated let me let me give you a
statistic here
a friend of mine just told me the other
day um
you know there's only two self-described
democratic socialists sitting in the
in the congressional house in the united
states on the democrat side
there's only two the rest of them are
moderates and most of the moderates are
moderate moderates you know
now those two attract a disproportionate
amount of attention partly because
they're incredibly savvy social media
users
whereas the moderates aren't at all and
and and our
technology are blind technologically in
that sense but
you know i guess i wonder how much
conscience scouring
everyone's asking themselves that i
suppose now how much conscience scouring
is in order after the events on the hill
last
last week or two weeks ago well i think
that would have been
that would have been shocking to a lot
of us and and should be
and i mean it's it's it's it's obviously
a con it's a concern
i understand much more in the european
context because i know it much
better i do i don't know
i think i think i have a fairly good
idea
of what what's hiding in the woodshed in
america
to use the coal comfort farm analogy i
think i know that there is
something nasty in the woodshed on the
right
but i've never believed that it's it's
got
any chance of persuading the gop
to adopt its platform you know i think
there are there are some nasty things in
the woodshed
in every society and on both political
sides
and the question of maturity in your
political system is
the extent to which you keep that
woodshed locked
right now it seems to me that in in
britain for instance is a country i know
best
i've spent more time in than any other
country
in britain i'm fairly confident in our
politics that
that we have that would shed very
closely locked you know
when when when a maniac uh
killed a labour mp several years ago the
late joe cox
and shouted britain first we had nobody
in britain
nobody on the political right who said i
think we've got to understand the
grievances of the attacker
we had nobody there nobody nobody wants
that anywhere near the political system
so what about the grievances what do you
think's happening in the us
on the right with regards to the
grievances of the capitol hill
protesters
well um here seems to me to be the
problem
but on the political left and i saw this
myself that i was
i was in portland and i was in seattle
on my travels before the election
and i saw the immiserated state that
antifa and blm
have turned those cities into i was
disgusted by what i saw
uh i was disgusted by the fact that i
i spent several nights with antifa in
portland
and seeing them and being mixed up with
them undercover obviously
seeing what they were doing to attack
federal buildings and so on i was just
horrified i've seen quite a lot of the
world i've seen a number of war zones
i've traveled all across africa and the
middle east and the far east i've seen a
lot of things
i've never seen a first world city like
that i've never seen that in a democracy
never and it's horrific and i was
horrified once more
by the fact that my left-wing friends
with with noble exceptions like brett
who i mentioned earlier
my left-wing friends in america didn't
want to hear about it or even concede
that i've seen with my own eyes what i'd
seen
because they just feared that if you
concede that's happening then you allow
trump in and so they've been willing on
the american left for years now
to excuse and in many cases at a very
senior level
actually extol political violence
we have we have cnn presenters and
democrat representatives
willing to say things like the
protesters not only
you know um mustn't stop they shouldn't
stop they should keep going and these
aren't these aren't obscure figures that
they're people like kamala harris the
vice president-elect
who were willing to play with
encouraging along
the protests that were roiling america
last night
and so and so in that in that situation
it wouldn't surprise me for a moment
if there were people on the political
right
willing to say all make all sorts of
excuses
and say well the election is happening
but that's where the right
will go wrong that's where the right
will go wrong and i think it has to be
totally clear
and instead of just pointing out a
double standard has to actually do
something different and say you know
we are not going to excuse for a moment
people assaulting federal agents
and breaking their way into federal
buildings and
and and causing the death of a policeman
we on our side
will not in any circumstances give
cover to people doing that we will say
it's wrong
and we will say it's wrong even if the
left keeps on saying that it's form of
violence
isn't wrong because the only way out of
this is if we
show people by demonstrating by living
by extolling the way out of it
that is the only answer okay so so let
me ask you
another question you know i can i can
two questions i guess i can hear
the voice of a liberal friend of mine a
good friend of mine in
in my head while you're talking and
saying it's disingenuous at a time like
this
two weeks after the capitol hill assault
to talk about
the antifa movements in portland and in
seattle
because they're of a different magnitude
the
what what happened in washington was on
the order of an insurrection and
so that's the first objection and the
second one is
that um i i had a brief discussion with
my wife
about um trump's claim that the election
was stolen
and so i've been running this margin of
error problem over in my head
say there was a he he he was defeated by
a small
margin relatively small margin now
the the compelling piece of evidence
that he lost in my estimation is the
fact that
and i believe this is right that of 90
court challenges that the trump
administration has brought forward
only one has been upheld and that
includes the decisions of the judiciary
where the judiciary was fundamentally
republican in its
in its in its nomination and in its
origin and so
but and her response was well you've
been saying for years that the judiciary
has become increasingly corrupted by
left-wing
activists let's say which is really
something that's happened to a large
degree in canada
how do you know that the judiciary
itself isn't
irredeemably corrupt and but i mean
i'm just i'm not willing to to
go that far i don't believe for a moment
that
republican nominated judiciary members
have been corrupted by left-wing
propaganda to the point where they
overthrew the american election
but but it's
the fact that that idea emerges is a
real indication of breakdown in this
trust that you've been
you know in this fundamental level of
trust that we've been describing all
right so i'm going to let you riff on
those
well first of all yes in order to look
i have uh i have endless messages
as i'm sure you do now from um from
people on the american right
gop voters who want to persuade me that
the election
was stolen and that everybody has let
trump down
and in order to believe that you have to
not only believe that all of those
courts
uh were wrong and were corrupted in some
way
but for instance vice president pence
was corrupted
and mitch mcconnell was right right
exactly yes
all the senior you know people who okay
so it's worth dwelling it's worth
dwelling on this for a moment because
lots of viewers are going to have this
as a question they're going to be
wavering with regard to their attitude
towards the election
so what we're saying is that the
fundamental here's the reasonable
perspective
it was very close no doubt there were
irregularities
however yes when trump challenged the
integrity of the vote even the judiciary
that would have been ideological
ideologically tilted towards him and
even nominated by him in some
circumstances
over ruled his objections in
the vast majority of cases plus you just
said
you also have to hypothesize that mike
pence was somehow got to and that all of
the right-wingers the republican
people on the right who are who refused
to go along with trump's claim that the
election was stolen all those people
were subject to the same corruption so
the only person that's allowed to be
pristine
from that perspective is trump himself
everywhere or else there's betrayal and
i would strongly urge people apart from
anything else to look at the absurdity
of that idea
that the perfect the only perfect person
in the united states
is donald j trump really
have you never had any doubts about his
character
have you never wondered about his
priorities
and have you never have you never uh
allowed yourself to succumb to the
temptation of gleefully using trump as a
weapon against people that who have
annoyed you in the past
some and and is your attraction towards
trump not generated in large part by a
kind of resentment that you wouldn't be
willing to
pri proudly admit publicly
you have to learn and and now you're in
a situation where you have to think that
he's
he's the only paragon of virtue this is
not a this is not a road that i would
recommend
traveling down absolutely and i worry i
worry that among other things
if the opportunity cost to the democrats
of not can not recognize
the democrats had four years where they
could have realized that they lost to
trump
in spite of the american public knowing
who he was
yes not that they didn't know his
character or his flaws but they knew all
of them and they voted for him anyway
that's a heck of a lesson to learn from
and they should have spent four years
trying to learn from it
and they didn't and well i don't know i
don't know if they didn't you know it
i think this this tangles us back up
with the problem that we were discussing
to begin with
like i've worked reasonably closely with
the greg hurwitz is yeah who did these
ads i met him with you
that's right that's right you did you
did that i forgot about that
and we we've talked also about the
collapse of the grand narrative like
it's not easy for the moderates on the
democrat side to get the stage
partly they don't know how they're
they're not social media experts by any
stretch of the imagination
and they may have some some of the
contempt
that is associated with inability with
regard to using the new media forms
they're not savvy in that regard and
they may have learned
at least in part but i don't think they
know how to control the ideologues on
the left and it's partly because they
they don't know how to put forth an
alternative narrative well
here's one very straightforward one that
the american left could do it could
recognize
you can be proud of your country and
feel this broadly speaking been a great
force for good in the world
without being a reprehensible person
yes absolutely that's a very good place
to start well i would say the message
messages the messages that have been put
out by this particular
uh group and the candidates that they
have supported
would agree with that statement and and
okay so so they're
yeah but but the problem the point is
they could have worked
more on that they could have worked to
try to make the
deplorables feel somewhat
um alienated
yes they that they heard that they
didn't want to make their lives more
painful
they wanted to lessen the pain that
could have been that could have been
cheese but but but the point is that now
there's a risk of the same opportunity
cost on the american right
that they're going to spend four years
with this
obsession over the election that's just
passed that
massive amount of attention of voters
and of thinkers and of outlets and of
money
and much more is going to be dedicated
first of all
to this attempt to prove everyone other
than the trump
family let america down in
the last few months and secondly that of
course he's going to continue to be
caught up with the trump train
and that he will haunt not just american
politics but specifically
uh republican politics okay so let's
talk about let's talk about this
impeachment move then be
so my sense was that
my sense is that in some way trump is
better ignored than persecuted
yes and the reason i believe that is
because
of this move towards paranoid
conspiratorial thinking that i see
emerging everywhere and the last thing
you want to do to people who are
becoming paranoid is to persecute them
and absolutely for the democrats have
if the democrats are going to prosecute
trump
i shouldn't say persecute not in that
context anyways if they're going to
prosecute trump
they need to figure out how to detach
the prosecution of trump
from the persecution of people who voted
for him
yes right that's a very tricky thing to
do and so
i think it would be better to let him go
with a whimper than
to let him go with a bang well he is
here's one way by the way
um i mean i know when i was writing
about blm protests last summer i
at any by the way i mean i make a
suggestion here by the way the american
media is much
much more corrupted than the british
media you know we still have a much
wider variety of platforms in the uk and
allow people
a wider and better array of opinion than
the american media which is almost
totally sunk not completely but almost
totally
in britain we don't have quite simple
why do i say that because
no editor of mine would allow me to
claim that everyone who went on a blm
march
looted no editor of mine would allow me
to write that
if i even tried it and i wouldn't i
would immediately have my first edit
back
saying you can't claim that
because everybody who was upset at the
death of george floyd last summer
did not go and loot the local nike store
some people did it was too large a
number
and there were too many people giving
cover for them and
and so on but you can't say they all did
right
so let's play the same standard are you
allowed to pretend that everyone who
attended the capitol hill demonstration
the other week
was responsible for the most
reprehensible people and their actions
no you shouldn't do that are you allowed
to pretend that all republican voters or
trump supporters were responsible for it
no you shouldn't be allowed to do that i
mean we could
try to encourage not unless you want to
live with the consequences
absolutely we could try to hold people
to that standard it's a perfectly
reasonable
it would have been journalism 101 in
america until a few years ago
it's only as they say because of the
totally corrupted nature of the american
media
that that it's possible for that to
happen by the way can i just give a
quick um
as it were a parenthesis on that i was
just writing a piece yesterday about
uh andy no um and uh his forthcoming
book unmasked which i blurbed and
uh is now the number one best-selling
book on amazon
happily um but but i read one of the
reports on
the again i don't get stuck on the
antique thing because the the left-wing
uh
the democrat friend in your head will be
saying he's talking about antifa again i
want to get this
possible yeah point to an example of the
corruption of the american media
the american media reporting on the
antifa protests outside the bookstore in
portland and other places
trying to force them not to stock andy's
book
the reports on that said things like and
this with these weren't
you know unusual or fringe publications
but
abc and other networks said things like
andy no who claimed to have been
assaulted and hospitalized by antifa in
i said what is this claimed to be
either the journalist in question was
hospitalized
or he was not it's not hard to find that
out
it's not hard to satisfy it so that you
accurately represent to your readers
what happened one day in 2019
you don't need to do these things that
signal
that you don't agree with the
interpretation of the individual in
question which you believe
might be attributed to you if you
accurately report the facts
it's in these little slippages that the
american media has gone so badly wrong
and in as a result the american
political debate has helped to go so
badly so
let me let me offer something that might
be an analog to that maybe
um and this might also be viewed by
listeners or viewers as concentrating on
rearranging the deck chairs when the
ship is sinking but in any case
um last week the biden harris
uh organization put out a tweet with a
little video
and it was joseph biden discussing
what he was going to do to small
business owners that had been decimated
by this terrible pandemic and
then he listed all the identity politics
groups that would be preferentially
treated now he could have i watched that
and i thought that was a big mistake
he could have because he's at the height
of his ability to set his own agenda and
not to pander to the radicals on the
left
if he can't do it right now he's never
going to be able to do it
um he should have said people have been
devastated by this pandemic small
business owners we're going to do
everything we can to help them
starting with those who have been
affected the most which is a perfectly
reasonable place to start but
he had to list asians latinos
women uh people of color he may not have
listed that particular category
certainly blacks
um yeah and it seemed to me to be
completely super
super super superfluous
and and one of those small slips of the
sort that you're describing that lead to
this
tip this positive feedback loop exactly
i saw that video as well i was horrified
i thought
you if you you're the incoming president
you won the election you have the most
important opportunity now to help heal
america and you're pulling this
well and you also have something obvious
to do in front of you all biden
all biden has to do there's nothing he
has to do
except immunize the population as fast
as possible
it's like he's got a the clearest
mandate of any president
that i can remember because the problem
is self-evident
it's like the pandemic is terrible it's
it's
killing people and it's driving them
crazy well that's
that's absolutely i mean we should get
on that because this is one of my other
big fears
that the era of the pandemic it's
the worst possible time to have an
overarching conspiracy
narrative introduced to the system by
the american president
i mean the outgoing american president
it's a very very bad
time that's for sure donald j trump must
know this
it's it's one of the fears that
conservatives always had about him was
that he was going to pull some
crap like this at the end you know it
was one of the reasons why
a lot of good people wouldn't join the
administration
why they wanted to keep a million miles
away from him
and this is a very very dangerous and
reprehensible
thing for him to have done in recently
yes well you can see his
you can see his essential narcissism
manifest itself
like it seems to me quite likely that a
large
that 75 percent of trump believes what
he's saying
can't conceive of the fact that he lost
the election and
and i'm i mean maybe that's not relevant
although
i think it's it i'm always trying to
understand him from a psychological
perspective
but i think his narcissism is so great
that he's willing to
risk it appears that he's willing to
risk everything in order to
to maintain his belief in victory yes
including the republican including
conservative voters and and yes and more
importantly the republic
i think it's completely reprehensible
and i know there will be people watching
who support trump and will be furious i
still think it's very very important
well look we
already we already we already walked
through
why supporting trump at the moment is
something that needs to be rethought
and we should i want to get back to that
just for one moment
look the problem is is that if you want
to maintain your support for trump under
the current conditions that you're going
to make yourself a lot more politically
radical than you were last week
because you have to swallow so much more
than you did
two weeks ago say or three weeks you
have to believe that absolutely every
institution in american life is totally
corrupted
and that the only incorrupt uncorrupted
thing is donald j trump and
me right and both of those like each of
those things is not true and the
combined the combination of them is even
less true yes
so so so it's very very important that
people realize that
donald trump was in a
in a society that was very close already
to conflagration
and he started playing with the matchbox
in a very dangerous way from the moment
of the evening of the election when he
said that he thought he'd won it
already and his insistence that he has
won it still to this moment
is a deeply corrupting influence on all
of american politics
and it's going to do enormous damage to
everyone on the right of politics
everywhere in the world
for the foreseeable future so i i i
think it was reprehensible he did
however
i add this to the fact that we're
already in this era i mean since since
we last spoke jordan
if we had when we last spoke if either
of us had said to the other
that the citizenry of all of our
countries will be confined to our houses
throughout 2020 and 2021
and made not to see our friends and our
closest
family in many cases and not to be
allowed to go to the funerals of loved
ones
and much much more and that just basic
things like shopping for essential goods
would become problematic
if either of us had sent this to the
other one when we last spoke
we wouldn't be able to foresee the
circumstances in which
such a horror show occurred we've been
in the middle of this horror show
we're still in it in our respective
countries and so again
we already have a very dangerous
situation occurring where we are all
even
more in our solitudes than the social
media systems have already made us
we've already lost almost all of our
remaining
social antennae we don't have the
ability to feel
exactly what it is in a normal situation
like down the pub
or talking with friends in a normal
situation over a cup of coffee we've
lost
all of that in the last thing so it's a
very bad idea
there's nowhere that isn't a catastrophe
and so it's very easy to believe that
there's catastrophe everywhere even
where there isn't
because because and in this situation
our most important our most important
duty it seems to me
is to hold on as much as we can
in this very very choppy time
and not fall into conspiratorial
thinking
or vengefulness
or excuse of violence
or resentment resentment legitimization
of
actual political or non-political means
and much more that's what we could point
out we could point out you know that
the democrats are making a conservative
argument with regards to the election
they're saying look
the institutions worked
therefore we're the valid government but
before they can make the claim that
they're the valid government they have
to accept the claim that the
institutions worked
and the conservatives shouldn't object
to that because the conservatives
believe that the institutions are valid
and so it's up to everyone right now to
maintain their faith in the validity of
the institutions
and to not overreact and to remember
that we've all been driven half out of
our
out of our minds or maybe more by this
enforced isolation and the fear that
the pandemic has produced and that
that's also opened the door to
a political catastrophe on the heels of
the biological catastrophe
yes everyone needs to breathe deeply and
wait for the damn vaccination
it's only going to be a few more months
before with any luck before this is
brought
under control we don't want to burn down
the ship just before it gets into port
this is this is one of the reasons why
you know i i've
again i mean you know you get criticism
from making this point and largely at
the moment from a
an increasingly conspiratorially
inclined right
but you know i don't believe that
the last the last year is simply some
kind of
prelude for democratic governments
coincidentally across the entire world
to fundamentally reprogram our species
or something like that
i i don't i don't see it i think there's
all sorts of criticism i think that
we've made the economy too secondary in
a discussion on the public health
for my taste but again if we had a
mature political discussion in any of
our countries it wouldn't
it would have involved as you know i've
discussed this before in aristotelian
terms
to do with immigration but i can do the
same thing in relation to the pandemic
which is
you have competing virtues of
eating almost seriousness
you have the public health and you have
the economy
and for a time in all of our societies
we over prioritize the public health
maps and under prioritize the economy
and if you don't have an economy then at
some point you don't have a public
health system or anything like it
and you end up in the situation of a
country where the the the poor and just
just much more likely to just die right
and so we sacrificed we sell what we're
doing is sacrificing long-term public
health
for short-term gains
on the hospital front and that's
actually not surprising
like i've thanked my lucky stars many
times in the last year that i'm not in a
position to be making those decisions
because it must be
hell what we need to all step back and
think look we might get lucky
there's a dozen vaccines that are that
are making their way to market many that
have already arrived and
a few months is a hell of a long time
when you're living through it but not
very long time when you think about it
in retrospect and so if we're smart
we're gonna
write this out here's an example of
where the whole thing
can both be mended and can go awry one
thing i've tried
to alert some people to in the last year
has been
um are we sure that it's are we sure
that for instance
it's worth our gdp's crashing and our
and our state borrowing soaring
in this fashion for this virus the
answer might be yes
but if it's yes then you have to be
pretty sure
that nothing like it's going to happen
again and i'm not at all sure of that
i'm not at all sure that among other
things because the country that gave us
this virus is led by a communist regime
that has done everything it can to cover
over how the virus came about
and so here's one of the risks we have
in in the era we're going into
um the question of how to make sure that
nothing like this ever happens again
is likely to be subsumed and forgotten
about
among other things because a lot of
energy is going to be expended by people
in fruitless and conspiratorial pursuits
which will include conspiratorial
pursuits against everyone in government
in their respective countries
and we will we will lose the opportunity
for instance to hold the ccp to account
or to make sure that they don't give us
another virus like this in a couple of
years time because
we also know from this this last year
that we live in societies which are
are dominated by risk aversion
and a highly litigious i mean many of
the firms that will
will not come back will not come back
because they were in fear that one
employee
might get the virus if they returned too
early to the office
and then sue their employer for instance
all of these are
they're not the deepest problems in a
society but they're
in terms of the technocracy of a society
they are very serious problems and need
addressing
i re i worry that we're going to address
none of this
because of energy is expended in
fruitless directions
and i wonder if we can't just somehow
again
come and come across ways to solve
problems
and that can be done by trust being
built
across political divides well that so
that's that's a big part of this
is that i would say another
if one piece of advice is to understand
what you're sacrificing by continuing to
support trump under these conditions
another piece of advice would be
to risk trust
yes at the present time you know yes
we've been through in the west we've
been through
crises of various sorts in the past and
managed them quite
successfully all things considered and
you could point to the pandemic response
and
look at all the things that have been
positive about it
the biggest of those being the dozen or
so vaccines or more that are
in the pipeline and that have been
produced with unbelievable
speed and and apparent utility
and i'm praying that that's the case
knowing full well that you know
vaccinating 100 million people with a
relatively unproven chemical
is a dangerous enterprise but i'm
praying that it goes well and
i'm praying as well that that trust
i've been thinking increasingly i wrote
about this in my book that's coming out
in march about trust as a form of
courage
right rather than because naive trust is
useless and anybody who's been hit
is no longer naive and so maybe no
longer trusting but you can replace that
with a trust that's
born out of courage and if you manifest
trust
even across a political divide you call
to the best in the person across that
divide
by saying look i'm willing to trust you
knowing full well that you're as big a
snake as me
so that's what we need at the moment and
i
and i'm i'm hoping biden well i mean i
he has a he is a great burden and i hope
that he can be
pragmatic and concentrate on the real
problems and
and help us put i was looking i was
reading your book and i kept thinking
this sounds like the past
to me because the pandemic has switched
things around so dramatically it's like
well this is so 2018 or or
and and maybe it's not maybe it's still
valid for today but
maybe the pandemic has changed
everything too and you know
we can put some of these
trivial and adolescent preoccupations
behind us and concentrate on the real
problems at hand
so some people listening will have heard
me say this before but when um
when the pandemic first struck uh in
2020 i was
under the i for a moment i mean i
thought a lot of things like all of us
one of my thoughts the secondary thought
was
um oh well at least that'll see off all
the identity politics
nonsense i thought well you know no
one's going to have much
time for playing gender games
if we're all going to lose the
significant swathe of our loved ones
and i thought for a time i thought i
thought well no that'll make the subject
of the madness of crowds look like a
sort of dated
a dated book already like you know one
of these books written just before a
catastrophe which
which wipes out the relevance of the
book in question
and i sort of had i had that feeling for
for
a few weeks and then i saw the same
stuff coming in
the same games being played and then of
course after the death of george floyd i
saw
you know one of the subjects i take on
in the book race
just blow up and i say in the updated
version
you know that was that was my experience
of it was in the way i was i was hoping
my book was going to be irrelevant and
then yeah and then suddenly it seemed to
be right over the target
again and um
and and you know and it's it's strange
because
because i felt i felt already that what
i'd seen and just
and what i'd warned about had just
exploded
just after i'd warned about it and
as you know you've had this experience i
mean it's very worrying because
you see the speed at which things pick
up and the
and the and the violence it just catches
faster than you'd ever feared
that's a characteristic of positive
feedback loops
they spiral out of control unbelievably
quickly and before we knew it you know
in britain
suddenly winston churchill was a
reprehensible figure
yes overnight um um and
i resisted that as i always do i
resisted the
attempt to smuggle in a new narrative
about
everything in my my society and country
my country's history
under cover of a terrible policeman's
actions in minnesota
but i think most people felt at that
moment that they were on the back foot
if they believed as i do that their
society had
a lot to be said for it rather than this
horrible hostile rewriting that was
being attempted
on the behalf on the back of an incident
awful as it was in minnesota and i and i
just
i but i saw the speed and the
recklessness with which people tried to
push in
a new story and then i suppose one of
the things i thought about was well
what are the things that i suggest in
the madness of crowds as being ways out
and are they still working would they
still be relevant in this situation and
perhaps i would
say this but i i do find that the
answers i
give i mean they're not the most
specific in a way but i try not to be
specific i try to give them the deepest
most
widely applicable answers i can you talk
about
you talk about forgiveness and i figured
that would be a good way for us to close
out this discussion you know and i think
that that's
you know i think that that's that's a
topic upon which much meditation could
be expended
you know we have to live with each other
the left wingers have to live with the
trump voters and the trump voters have
to live with the identity politics types
and
we have good solid institutions and i
think we need
in the next coming months to put out
our put out our hands to our to those
who oppose us
knowing full well that we might be burnt
in the attempt but to do it nonetheless
and to keep doing it because
the all the alternatives are much worse
unless you want to see things burn
and yes most people are moderate and
reasonable
yes and uh will feel deep
embarrassment at some point if they
allow their own political side
to run to its extremes they will you
know i
i think this about i i don't get stuck
in them again but very quickly
i think this about about what has
happened in recent weeks on the
republican right
there will be and should be some
embarrassment
that a president a republican president
was able to stand in front of a very
large crowd
mainly comprising patriots and to say
words which were if
there were not incitement direct
incitement but were real
fighting talk and raised the question of
exactly what it is he thought the crowd
should do you know and i think he didn't
ever want to make that
too clear even to himself i think i read
the speech carefully and
yes there is it's it's it's here's what
i think
this is what i would suggest you do if
you were true patriots
right and i think this is this is a
reckless reckless speech
and i think that people should have the
decency on
any and all political sides to say that
recklessness you don't have to go all
the way to excitement the
reckless speech you've got to be careful
with
and you've got to try to limit it and
you've got to try to call it out where
you can
and not just enjoy it because at some
point it will lead to something which
will
humiliate you and humiliate your side
and much much more it will make you feel
shame
and you want to try to avoid that so in
the manners of crowds one of the things
as you say
i i refer to is is this and i write a
chapter on is the importance of
forgiveness and
and it's quite easy when you're caught
up as you well know and you're caught up
in the sort of day-to-day
fights that are going on and the endless
information and
and new examples and new lows
that are always being hit it's quite
easy to to lose sight of the
of the deep underlying answers to some
of our present performers
but i'm i'm absolutely persuaded that
one of them lies in forgiveness
and one of the reasons i i go there is
obviously
we live in this society and the social
media has exacerbated it beyond
all previous human belief we live in
societies which are very eager
to demonstrate us and them
instincts uh without having to leave
your bed
you know you can shame somebody you can
you can try to destroy them you can do
your bit
to pick up on something somebody said or
once said and go for them and pummel
them and destroy them and everything
every future they've got you can do that
but you should also know how dangerous
it is and my hope has always been that
the more people saw this the more they
would step back from this manner of
living
but the thing the thing that that struck
me and made me write
about the forgiveness thing in
particular actually was
was something that hannah aaron who
participated perhaps isn't a thinker i
think over
highly of actually um all sorts of
criticisms of her like a lot of people
have
um but um there's a lecture that hannah
aaron delivered in the 50s
i happened to read a few years ago it
just made an enormous impression on me
because aaron says um in this lecture
something i think
will be highly pertinent to a lot of
people listening which is that
is that we've always as human beings had
a one worry in particular which is how
do we act in the world
how do we act in the world how do we put
one's foot in front of the other
how do we put one word in front of them
of another and and and say the next one
and decide what our actions should be
day to day never mind year to year
and we all have the terror of action and
young people in particular have it
because they haven't tried it out enough
they haven't they haven't yet made their
mistakes and you've got to make your
mistakes
in order for anything else to lose some
of the terror of the question of action
in the world
but hannah aaron says something so
interesting in this lecture she says
she says as human beings we only ever
really
found one mechanism to
make the horror of acting in the world
less horrific
and that was the mechanism that we know
is forgiveness
which in in religious terms you can add
to
is also the possibility of redemption
which perhaps in a highly secularized
society we ought to also think about
more
not just forgiveness but redemption and
and and i say that
this is therefore something that we
should all be trying to exercise in our
lives because
we sure as hell know that we as
individuals do not want to ourselves be
treated
without ever having forgiveness
demonstrated
to us by other people towards us we
don't want to live in a situation where
when we
want to slip if we once we're the wrong
thing or make the wrong move or
or make the wrong move on someone else
or or
or say the wrong thing we don't want to
live in the world where we at any moment
can destroy ourselves
catastrophically and unmendably we don't
want to live in that world ourselves
so why would we expect other people to
live in that world or to want to live in
that world
and the mechanism therefore that we all
have to in our political and
non-political lives because politics
isn't
that damn well isn't everything but in
our
our political and non-political lives we
have to work
at finding ways to forgive and and and
there's a lot to say about this but this
is this is seems to me to be one of the
absolute
keys in our time that we all need to
work on
how can i forgive a person who has done
a wrong to me
how can i allow somebody else who may
have made a mistake
to to live again for it to live again
it's not it's not the same thing as you
well know i mean it's not the same thing
as
being willfully naive it's not about
just
giving people uh you know second time
it's
the nature of the apology matters deeply
as well of course
the nature of the seeking for redemption
or seeking for forgiveness matters
you know we know that you can't just
sort of say oh well yeah they're that
sorry about that and and move on
but it has to be deep and deeply meant
but when when the feeling of that
is deeply meant and is deeply offered it
should not be
retributively and deliberately
willfully smashed away
in order to win a short-term political
or other point
and so i think that's a good i think
that's an excellent place to
to end the conversation and for everyone
who's listening to
consider deeply in the upcoming months
you know we want to extend
an intelligent and compassionate hand
across the political divide and
hope that we don't rock the boat any
further than nature has already decided
to rock it
and maybe we'll make it through this
dire time and
put things back together and
for all the right wingers who've been
tossed out of power in the united states
as you'll get your opportunity again
soon enough and
in the meantime you better wish your new
president well
good talking to you douglas very nice to
see you to see you i can't tell you what
a pleasure it is to see you jordan
thanks very much i'm i hope we talk
again soon
i really hope so
[Music]
you